why would you say that you think Nancy
Pelosi is a better Catholic than Joe
Biden only because he is more prominent
and I think he has more responsibility
to live his faith properly and to
respect his but having more of a
responsibility is not the same thing to
say he he is a better Catholic
that when he commits the sin of Scandal
it's it's more egregious than what she
does sure because though theoretically I
mean she's the head of one of the houses
of one of the three branches of
government or was until very recently
but he's the president of the United
States it's a figure that is imbued with
a kind of monarchical quality almost and
so I'm sure Pelosi thinks all the same
stuff yeah it's just I just think the
sin of Scandal is is sure more severe
for Bible